and what you want to do is you want to
factor it first so X minus 4 times X
plus 3 is greater than 0 and then what
you want to do is you want to set these
factors equal to 0 so what that'll give
you is it'll give you negative 3 for
this group and positive 4 for this group
now we want it to be greater than 0 not
equal to 0 so these are going to be open
okay so it doesn't include negative 3 or
4 the next thing you want to do is you
want to do a sign analysis you want to
pick some points in each of these
intervals each of these regions and test
to see if it's positive or negative so
let's pick negative 4 if we pick
negative 4 we get a negative times the
negative because that's negative 1 and a
negative times a negative is a positive
so I'm just gonna put a little plus sign
here if we pick 0 we get a negative
times a positive which is a negative and
if we pick positive 5 that'll give us a
positive times a positive which is a
positive now since we're looking for
where this is greater than 0 we're
looking for where it's going to be
positive so we want this region and we
want this region and the way you would
write that in interval notation is from
negative infinity so we're going from
left to right low to high up until
negative 3 parentheses because it
doesn't include negative 3 Union 4
parenthesis cuz it doesn't include 4 to
positive infinity of course we can never
reach infinity that's an open bracket
okay parenthesis so any point that it's
in these regions would make this
inequality true okay so that's just a
regular inequality now we're going to
talk about the rational inequalities and
this example here the first thing I
would recommend you do is just factor it
and then we'll set the factors to 0 so
if we do that we get X minus 2 X plus 1
all over X minus 3 ok we're going to go
to the number line and we're gonna plot
these set these factors to 0 and plot
those points so we get X is 3 okay so
I'll just put 3 here we get 2
so I'll put two there and negative one
week I put them in an order from lowest
to highest and then what you want to do
is you want to pick a point in each of
these intervals and test to see if it's
positive or negative before we do that
we're looking for where this is less
than or equal to zero
now if the numerator is zero and the
denominator is not simultaneously zero
then this is going to be equal to zero
so at two and negative one that's going
to make the expression okay equal to
zero but the denominator we know cannot
be zero because you can't divide by zero
so over here at x equals three even
though this is less mu equal to zero we
can't divide by zero this is going to be
an open ok circle it doesn't include
that point now we're gonna test our
intervals so let's see if we can put in
negative two so we've put in negative
two we're gonna get a negative times a
negative and that would also be negative
so a positive divided by a negative is a
negative if we do let's say zero is
always a good one that's gonna be
negative times a positive divided by a
negative so that's a negative divided by
a negative which is positive so we're
just doing a sign analysis we're not so
concerned with the number just whether
it's positive or negative and if we pick
two point five we're gonna get positive
positive and negative so two pauses
multiply to a positive divided by a
negative is a negative and if we pick
four we get positive positive positive
so that's going to be positive now we're
interested in where it's less than or
equal to zero so it's just going to be
in this region here and this region here
and so again if we think about going
from low to high or negative infinity to
positive infinity this is going to be
negative infinity to 1 I'm using a
square bracket because it includes one
okay
Union to two three
it includes two doesn't include three
site use a parenthesis okay so is curved
for three square bracket for two because
it includes two and so if you're in
these two regions that's going to be
this expression is going to be less than
or equal to zero okay the last one a
little bit trickier what we want to do
is want to get everything on one side of
the inacol
set it to zero okay and proceed from
there so let's do that so I'm gonna
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm going to
subtract -2 over X minus 4 get a common
denominator which is just going to be X
plus 4 X minus 4 here I'm going to
multiply by X minus 4 over X minus 4 so
that's going to give you 3 X minus 12
minus this is missing an X plus 4 so I'm
going to multiply the top and bottom by
X plus 4 so that gives you 2x Plus 8 and
if we combine like terms we get 3x minus
2x is 1 X negative 12 minus 8 is
negative 20 okay and then the
denominator we have X plus 4 times X
minus 4 ok now we're interested in where
this is greater than 0 we got everything
on one side want to set it to 0 so
greater than 0 so we're going to do the
same thing we did in the other problems
we're going to set all the factors to 0
a numerator denominator so we have 20 we
have 4 and we have negative 4 now
negative 4 and positive 4 okay it cannot
equal 0
so these are going to be open circles
and the numerator it can be 0 but we
want this to be greater than 0 so again
open circle if this was equal to x
equals 20 that would be a closed circle
these would still be open because you
can't divide by 0 okay so some important
points there and then now we're going to
test a point in each one of these
intervals let's pick negative 5 we get a
negative negative negative so negative
divided by positive is negative if we
pick 0 we get negative positive negative
so that's going to be positive if we
pick 6 that's going to be negative
positive positive which is negative and
if we pick a hundred that would be
positive positive positive which is
positive we're interested in where it's
greater than 0 so it's going to be here
and here so we're looking at negative 4
2 4 I'll just write it like that Union
20 to infinity okay
parentheses because it doesn't include
20 and doesn't include negative